こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーと
ダ)My　Name is ダンテ
久しぶりだね
ダ)久しぶりだね
我々と言ったらまず何かと言いますと
普通ににらめっこをダンテとしてもあれ何で
ちょっと　特殊なルールをつけましょう
ダンテも俺も　最近はね大分大人になったからしないけど
ダ)コメント欄で　よく言われるからちょっと気にしちゃって
なんてコメント来るの？
ダ)うるせーよとか
そんなこと言われるの？
俺も大人になろーかと
ふーん
ダンテも僕もね
発狂しないんで昔の気持ちを取り戻そう
今日は発狂しようや
ダ)やるか
というわけで、今日は
きゃああああああああああああああああ
よしやろ
ダ)今　1時やん
ルールは簡単だ
先に2回勝ったら勝ち
ダ)負けたらどうなるの？
ダ)絶対負けないからね
まじ本気だよ
では　行こう
さてと
明らかに笑ってるなみたいな
ははははみたいなだったら負け
3　2　1
発狂中
笑ったでしょ？
笑ったでしょ
3　2　1
発狂中
今のは笑ったでしょ
待って　すごいゲロ出っちゃた
3　2　1
発狂中
おえっ
今ので1　1です
これが最終勝負です
これで勝ったほうの勝ち
負けたほうはケツに銃をぶち込まれるんで
ダ)やだぁ
3　2　1
発狂中
はははっは
ああああああぁ
ちょっと待って　待って
やったことある？
無い
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
自分のケツに火薬銃ぶち込みます
音吸収出来るって
それはまじですか？
えっ　待って待って　ホントに怖い
ダ)いや　全然いけると思う
うわぁぁぁぁぁ
一発だけね
ほんとに一発だけだよ
ダ)一発だけ
罰ゲームです
よし　来い
あぁ　待って
OK　よし来い